what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future alright guys so we
get into it then we get into the trial
of Peter Parker and ooh man this is a
this story is interesting this story is
a unique circumstance it's a unique
snowflake that's what the story is it's
a very unique snowflake because of what
happens at the end and people who have
read spider-man Clone Saga are just like
oh god oh man I'm sorry Peter
it's it's rough it's a little bit rough
but what this does is this picks up with
the confrontation between Peter Parker
spider-man and Kaine this is actually
when they finally meet they finally go
face-to-face member Cain had just been
kind of make it life a nightmare for you
know for Ben Riley really more so than
Peter Parker but the whole idea was that
the husband Riley was a clone of Peter
Parker it all really just kind of came
back on Peter himself now the crazy
thing about this is that Peter had
previously broken out of jail before but
ultimately ended up going back in just
because of the fact that it was causing
more problems than he was worth and so
ultimately Ben Riley swapped places with
Peter Parker because to anybody out
there who saw the two they wouldn't know
the difference I mean all the way down
to like the fingerprint they're
basically the exact same and what this
did is an allowed Peter Parker to go
forward and figure out who Cain was and
why Cain was making life such a
nightmare for Peter himself now force
with Peter out and about this inevitably
leads towards a conversation between him
and Cain and what we actually end up
learning here is it came views himself
as more of an ally for Peter Parker than
an actual enemy and the reason why is
because of the fact that what Cain says
is that everything he's done so far has
been designed for the purpose of making
life an absolute nightmare for Ben Riley
because in the mind of Cain Ben Reilly
is a bad guy Ben Riley's the false one
Ben Riley is the clone he has no
business being here now this really kind
of turns the tables on everything just
because of the fact that up until this
point it was believed that Cain was just
a legit villain he was just a guy who
was a jerk and just going around and
trying to make life too rough for
everybody but again we didn't really
know what his motivation was we didn't
know what the basis behind his actions
were and so ultimately Peter Parker and
Cain end up
one another if for no other reason than
the fact that at the end of the day
Peter Parker cannot let an innocent man
go to jail now of course the whole idea
of who Caine is and what he's about is
revealed when Peter still fails to grasp
what it is a Caine's talking about and
so ultimately Caine pulls off his mask
and reveals the fact that he is a clone
of Peter Parker not only that he was the
first clone and that's really kind of
the crazy scenario here because but
regards to him revealing the fact that
he's the first clone we only get a brief
little impasse here what we're told by
Caine is that in the beginning you know
back with amazing spider-man 149 when
the jackal was going through and
creating clones of Peter Parker the
first one he made was Cain himself well
the problem was that there was a
degenerative you know illness with
regards to came in this sense that he
wasn't an exact duplicate he wasn't a
perfect clone and so what ultimately
ended up happening is the jackal tried
to get rid of Cain he literally just
tried to tried to kill him off now of
course Cain ended up making his escape
and ultimately kind of you know
meandering around the world in the same
way Ben Reilly did which ultimately
brought him back here but this is a
pretty huge revelation with regards to
the idea of the whole clone saga because
now it changes the motivation behind
everything
now of course ultimately Peter still
won't let Ben Reilly end up going to
jail for something he didn't do and so
Peter Parker just kind of you know walks
into the courtroom alongside Cain and
basically says look you know you have to
confess you have to tell people what's
going on now of course what is up
happening here is that because of the
fact that came had been looking to
consistently kill Ben Riley he was
always looking to simply eliminate him
in his entirety Cain ultimately goes
after Ben Riley and tries to kill him
off now force this is up seeing you know
Peter Parker everybody's stepping in and
ultimately came stepping down you know
once he's basically defeated and
actually held at gunpoint which is
really kind of a crazy situation and so
with Cain being in prison he literally
just confesses to all of his crimes you
know the murder of a former detective by
the name of Bruce Kennedy to the murder
of Doctor Octopus how it was it he did
it that he broke his neck the whole nine
yards and so the crazy thing about this
was that initially on the surface it
seemed like okay well now we're done
here like I'm in the Clone Saga is
pretty much over like everything's all
copacetic I mean the bad guy's been
captured you know Ben Riley still out
there but surely they can come to terms
and it doesn't work out that way instead
what is up happening is we actually see
a guy by the name of Seward who's
invoked here now for the people who have
never read anything about Clone Saga
I'm not going to go super in-depth into
a sewer trainer just because of the fact
that he has a really big part in this
story with the grand pooh-bah a
revelation at the end of the whole thing
I do not want to spoil that because it's
actually really really cool reveal and
super trainer has a pretty significant
role in it all but what we can say is
that we're Ben Riley was just kind of
traveling around the world and just
trying to live his life you know where
the fact that he was a clone and trying
to make a life for himself he eventually
came across Seward trainer and super
trainer it formed a bond with within
Riley that was very akin to father and
son a lot of the life lessons that were
there were sort of imparted to Ben Wiley
it was kind of like his own version of
Uncle Ben in a lot of different ways I
mean of course super trainer didn't die
in the same capacity that Uncle Ben did
but at the very least
soory trainer was able to impart a lot
of his own wisdom and his own experience
now the other half of this equation is
it Seward trainer is part of the Ben
Wiley landscape at the moment because of
the fact that there were suspected to be
complications with regards to Mary Jane
Watson and her baby and so what is up
happening has been Riley had actually
taken Mary Jane Watson to visits to her
trainer just to analyze her and make
sure there was nothing going on and
Seward trainer didn't find any problems
he was like you know you're going to
give birth to a healthy baby at least
that seems to be the case there won't be
any complications when the pregnancy as
far as we can tell but what ended up
happening is Seward trainer had also
analyzed you know the genes of Ben
Reilly himself and came to the
realization this story came to the
realization that the father of Mary Jane
Watson baby was a clone and so the
implication here was that Peter Parker
himself was the clone and not Ben Riley
now this gets kind of crazy here and the
reason why is because of the fact that
Stuart trainers like look guys all you
have to do is just kind of analyze
yourself test your own DNA now this is
where the story I mean if the story
hadn't gone off the rails by now this is
where it's fully off the rails maybe
there's no tracks this train is just
careening down the hillside it is uh
it's rough it's a little weird because
this is one of those things where Marvel
was trying to like thicken the plot real
is like oh man you think you know what's
going on but you have no idea and the
problem with this was that by this point
in time fans that had enough and that's
why we skipped over so much of that
stuff because it was totally unnecessary
I mean there were so many things that
had no reason to be in a story Judas
traveler and all that kind of stuff we
delved into him a little bit but only
insofar as we needed to to understand
the story at the time but the idea
while this was all going on we ended up
having miles war in the jackal who made
his escape and his goal was to basically
create an entire world of clones using
his carrion buyers so there were a lot
of unnecessary aspects to the story
because remember this was all supposed
to be a new status quo this was not
supposed to be a story art this is also
to be a pretty limited story that ended
up seeing Peter Parker basically removed
and Ben Riley taking his place and where
it was initially successful its spun out
so fast by editorial mandated it was
like just keep writing guys we don't
care what you write just keep writing
things SWAT Clone Saga on it and sell it
it got to the point where it was 200
some odd issues of just absolute
nonsense so that's why we skipped over
so much of that stuff I mean in all
honesty we could have covered it but by
the time we got to this point you would
have just been like okay I don't care
like I really don't care about the Clone
Saga and I guarantee almost nobody would
have been watching this video so it
would have been pretty rough I don't
even know if people are gonna watch this
video now I have no idea how many people
are gonna watch other people are just
like I've heard about that story don't
care so I I have no idea people are
going to respond but ultimately you know
because of the fact that Mary Jane
Watson kind of you know beseeches Peter
Parker and says look even if you're not
sure about this you know even if you
don't want to do this do it for me do it
for the baby at the very least it'll
give us a peace of mind Peter Parker
subjects himself to these tests and
basically goes through alongside Ben
Riley analyzing their DNA so on and so
forth we end up finding out that Peter
Parker is the actual clone at least
that's what we're told Peter Parker's a
clone and Ben Riley is the real one and
so so because of this it just kind of
spins things out I mean at this point it
really just kind of goes absolutely nuts
Peter Parker of course begins to begins
to lose his mind and in his rage in his
anger he actually backhands Mary Jane
Watson and hits her in the exact same
way that Hank Pym hit Janet Van Dyne so
again this is one of those things that
we talked about when it came to the
whole idea with regards to Hank Pym and
they kind of stigma that he encountered
that one off where he hit hit Janet Van
Dyne Peter Parker's done the exact same
thing Reed Richards backhanded Susan
storm on a multitude of occasions you
know back in the old 1960s 1970s stories
so that was one of the big things about
why hank pym fans get so bad out of
shape whenever something like that's
brought up but what this also does is it
really kind of sets the stage for the
future of a story in the sense that it
asked question what happens next like
what's going to go on now with regards
to Peter Parker actually having been
revealed
B to clone himself so again Pisa this
video is pretty short I mean it's not a
super lengthy one you know at this point
it just kind of leads into the idea of
you know this sort of ultimate fall out
of this ultimate event in this huge
revelation in terms of who it is it's
actually behind the Clone Saga and who's
behind you know the producing of all
these clones with regards to you know
Peter Parker and so on and so forth but
again I mean this is one of the reasons
this is one of the things that we did
you know we kind of went through here we
skim through a lot of this stuff we
ended up just kind of bypassing a lot of
things it's one of reasons why way to
solid what kind of pop another look I
know Clone Saga still with all kinds of
unnecessary stuff give me the core
stories on what happens if you can and
this is what we have I mean you know
that this is basically the core set of
events as it unfolds and this was again
just kind of a change in the landscape
you know it was designed to sort of
revitalized shift things up a little bit
the problem was that with this
revelation they had just kind of gotten
sick and tired of the Clone Saga they
were effectively done like look this
needs to wrap up and it needs to be
finished which of course will get you in
the next video when we cover the
conclusion of the Clone Saga but enemy
and then again it's the pretty short
video but if you guys are new here -
comments explain make sure you guys took
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]
Oh